état fédéral depuis peu la belgique
compte trois communautés au sud est du
royaume la région francophone des
ardennes correspond tout à fait à ce que
l'on appelle un pays une région petit
aisément repérables par ses
particularités culturelles ou
historiques professeur ardennais pur
sucre
armel job nous propose avec baigneuses
nu sur un rocher paru aux éditions
robert laffont de mieux connaître le
terroir qui est le sien voilà c'est à
propos de votre thérèse thérèse
attendait une miette monsieur josé
thérèse ma fille je dois causer avec
monsieur josé retourne au magasin va
mais non madame emma elle peut rester si
vous permettez je vous explique je
voudrais faire le portrait de votre film
le portrait de thérèse vous voulez dire
en faire une peinture
ben oui vu que je suis peintre ce serait
plutôt pour une peinture josé
agrémentent la plaisanterie de son
sourire le plus engageants thérèse le
lui rend découvrant ses dents blanches
comme la première neige
et puis elle se tourne vers sa mère avec
une mine est sonné et déjà implorante
oms a alors mam ça alors moins en
peinture ainsi donc en 1956 dans la
petite ville de ma cave au josé artiste
peintre qui a racheté la camionnette
d'un ami à lui peintre également mais en
bâtiment celui là c'est prend on s'en
doute de thérèse son modèle
laquelle lui échappe des doigts comme de
l'eau entre giono et clochemerle
s'ébauche alors une comédie humaine car
après notamment mayna la compagne de
josé est une collectivité marquée par la
guerre encore très présente dans les
esprits
armel job dit tout est trop mais sa
verve et plaisante